this morning on the dish a chef with a
near-perfect culinary pedigree born and
raised in Chicago
Greg Backstrom was attending a local
culinary school when he contacted a new
restaurant for help with a homework
assignment the restaurant was the
extraordinary Alinea and the assignment
turned into an internship and eventually
a full-time job later he worked at New
York's acclaimed per se and Blue Hill at
Stone Barns with its farm-to-table ethic
that influenced his current project his
first solo project Olmsted was named
food & Wine's restaurant of the year and
one of Bon Apetit best new restaurants
in America chef Greg Backstrom welcome
to vish tell us about this table and
especially this tree well it's actually
delicata squash so you can eat just like
a onion ring we we beer-batter it and we
fry them at the restaurant we sort of
serve it a little differently with we
make a catch about a green tomatoes nice
we have a rutabaga pasta so we it's it's
meant to look just like tagliatelle
pasta we tossed it with mushrooms and
truffles and butter and typically the
guests don't really even realize that
it's not possible till after they've
finished it nice this is just like a
go-to pork roast that I usually make for
my parents when I go home it's sparkline
wrapped in prosciutto you know a lot of
sage over the top of it and our bridge
this morning it's a lovely color I must
say yeah it's like it's Concord grape so
it's sort of like a Welch's grape juice
it's like going back to my roots well
thanks it tastes even better than the
grape juice I remember yeah Gregory I
read that you got some culinary training
well obviously it's some of the greatest
restaurants in the world but also in the
Boy Scouts yeah I was in the Boy Scouts
for really a long time and you know in
the beginning you know the parents are
doing a lot of the things for you but as
you get older as you learn how to do
things you then are just expected to do
those things right you know you're
making beef stew you're making very
simple you know boiled pasta but you
don't want to be the guy you know making
the worst possible the worst beef stew
depress your little group of friends Boy
Scout pressure yeah definitely your
first actual restaurant job
Wendy's Wendy's I wasn't gonna bring
that up
well we talk about a Lydia and per se
about Wendy's and the Boy Scouts yeah I
was there for like a year and a half
before I went off to culinary school
okay so humble beginnings but you did
intern and work at literally some of the
most influential great kitchens around
the world talk to us about Alinea and
what that was like
I mean Alania was like a this amazing
accident
I called Alania I reckon week before
they opened and and asked if I could
interview them if you know for the
school project well meanwhile these guys
are trying to open up the best
restaurant in the world yeah and so
somewhere there was some
miscommunication and I showed up at the
door and they thought I was there too
trail for a position to work there Wow I
was too embarrassed to say otherwise
though then I just sort of kept coming
back Wow Wow
and then a week after a week after that
the person that I was assisting quit and
so grant came up to me and said either
run with the opportunity or a hire
somebody else Wow
chain of events led you to Olmstead was
it scary opening a place on your own
after working in such distinguished
restaurants yeah I mean eventually you
eventually you come to the realization
that you know okay now you know how to
cook and it's in its time it's time to
open up a restaurant once I honed it in
once I really figured out okay I wanted
a small dining room but not too small
that I couldn't afford nice things the
small bar because I like to eat at the
counter or the bar when I go to a
restaurant
hmm I'm just some type of outside space
- two months went by and I found I found
Olmstead and I flew I picked up my dad
we threw a whole bunch of barnwood from
where I grew up and as a carpenter but
as a carpenter and he built the
restaurant Wow yeah it's such a small
budget that was unless he could do it or
I could go find it in some reclaimed
place in Brooklyn
exactly but that Boy Scout knowledge
came in handy about putting that
restaurant together chef's as I ask you
to sign this dish I will ask you the
question we always ask which is if you
could share this meal with anybody past
or present who would it be probably
spider-man but if spider-man existed I
probably so overwhelmed with
see you that wouldn't go well you're
already forecasting into the future with
your imaginary friends not the kind of
creativity that makes her a successful
chef and restaurateur chef Greg
Backstrom of Olmstead things here idiot
what do you serve spider-man sticky yeah
for more on chef Backstrom and the dish
head to our website at CBS this morning
dot-com